tu devrais pas aller là
[Musique]
on avait refusé
michaud
qu'est ce qui est arrivé à près de pékin
le shérif et là je croyais encore en
prison
j'ai sorti il ya quelques heures tu
voudrais quoi négocier tu sais
exactement à qui demander pour avoir ce
qu'on fait on va les voir tomber mon
père détestent les surprises je comprend
ce
qu'est ce qui va pas docteur cuite tu
peut nettoyer ça
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce qui les a poussé à faire
ça brigite représenter tout pour moi la
dernière fois qu'elle a été vue elles
sont venues ici chez quitte dans sa
maison alors voilà ce qu'il en est
résoudre la disparition de blue jean
becker ou housse commence à t'envoyer
john keats morceau par morceau jusqu'au
dernier lambeau
docteur keats compte beaucoup pour cette
ville cal est à l'intérieur quoi et toi
tu as envoyé mon seul fils régler ça et
que
m'a pas vraiment le temps de s'amuser
entre là-dedans troupe mon fils et tu
les autres provinces en or et bleu ras
rien fait du mal à mon fils et je vous
promets que vous allez crever tous les
trois
ma famille
la bâtisse est il c'est moi le shérif de
ce comté
les surtout pas quitter milan
on va faire la volonté du seigneur